frieden schaffen mit schweren waffen das
sind der westen offensichtlich als
alternativlos an nach den pixar putin
genauso offensichtlich auf diplomatie
und verständigung weist russland aus der
ukraine verjagen das ist das zu
waffen für die ukraine kann dass putin
stoppen jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet sind und bin
amerikanische politikwissenschaftlerin
und sie arbeiten hier in berlin am
institut für europäische politik ebenso
zugeschaltet ist egon ramms bundeswehr
und nato general außer diensten hier im
studio paul anton krüger hauptstadt
korrespondent der süddeutschen zeitung
und der publizist christoph schwennicke
kramnik dieser beschluss heute im
bundestag der ukraine jetzt also auch
mit schweren waffen auszustatten
massiv militärisch zu unterstützen kann
man jetzt sagen dass die ukraine die
deutschen als freunde und helfer
betrachten
ich muss sagen dass der antrag wirklich
so symbolträchtig ist auch gegen trainer
wurde das positiv aufgenommen und waren
daher ich heute gesehen habe und ich
muss sagen dass es gibt zwar anfang
meiner meinung nach wichtig erscheinen
einmal dass zum beispiel direkte
verhandlungen zwischen russland unserem
trainer unterstützt werden aber nicht
über die köpfe der ukraine sollten diese
verhandlungen stattfinden sondern man
würde nicht glauben würde dann das
interesse und die wünsche der kunden
stellen wichtig ist auch dass man jetzt
für die schwere waffen ausgesprochen hat
und mit blick auf die strecke gehen dass
man bereit ist nicht nur
[Musik]
nicht nur waffen symmetrischer bauarten
oder russischer beraten und liebe zu
liefern sondern auch westliche schwere
waren an dem trainer zu lieben und auch
diese daten und römischen soldaten aus
zu beten
allerdings wir müssen auch verstehen
dass dieses dokument nicht rechtlich
bindend ist und es ist das dokument
eigentlich noch die lesungen bleibt für
die zukunft auch die frage ob die wie
die regierung
bekannt reise zu seinen lieblingstieren
wird und an diesen forderungen die auch
jemand sagen wir haben es jetzt hat sich
die regierung mit diesem beschluss im
bundestag auch eine gewisse bein frei
geschaffen es gibt schon geplante
lieferungen von schweren waffen
möglicherweise kommen da noch welche
dazu kann man den sagen dass diese
waffenlieferungen die jetzt da zu
erwarten sind seelands die helfen und
putin das leben schwer machen
also wir müssen davon ausgehen dass auch
die ukrainische stadt kräfte in den
letzten wochen in den kriegswochen
verluste gehabt haben und schweren
waffen während russland in der lage ist
putin in der lage ist weitere
truppenteile weitere systeme aus dem
osten oder aus diesen norden russlands
richtung ukraine zu verschieden sind die
bestände der ukraine begrenzt das heißt
wenn die gerade diese hilfe nicht
bekommt dann fällt der krieg irgendwann
von ukrainischer seite in sich zusammen
oder wird noch schmutziger und wird noch
schwieriger zu führen das heißt die
lieferung schwerer waffen die
unterstützung der afghanischen
streitkräfte
sie wollen muss tatsächlich erreichen
wollen dass die ukraine eine chance sagt
auch nur eine chance auf diesen krieg zu
gewinnen der ständige es herrscht zwar
keine waffengleichheit zwischen ukraine
und russland aber so richtig die ukraine
über rollen kann putin jetzt nicht mehr
auch wegen der vielen
waffenlieferungen als jedenfalls sieht
es im moment nicht so aus egon ramms hat
gerade gesagt man braucht ja auch
weiterhin massive unterstützung aber die
tatsache dass jetzt putin da kein
durchmarsch mehr offensichtlich mehr
machen kann ist das ein ermutigendes
zeichen also diese frage ob putin einen
durchmarsch machen kann oder nicht die
würde ich tatsächlich lieber herren rams
überlassen also wenn ich mir die
landkarte anschaue dort wo sich im
moment die kämpfe abspielen dann kann
auf jeden fall aus meiner sicht aber
noch mal ich bin kein kein militär diese
schlimme schließlich schon zu ziehen
also diese einkesselung der ukrainischen
soldaten schon schon drohen und das
scheint ja im moment das ziel zu sein
und diese diese land spanien der nächste
mal zu ziehen und auch zu schließen in
der tat ist da bei weitem keine
waffengleichheit ich glaube da dann muss
man auch nicht militärexperte dafür
seien insofern ist es nachvollziehbar
und auch
politisch legitim
hier bei den ukrainern nach nachschub zu
sorgen ich staune nur etwas und da
erlaube ich mir vielleicht eine etwas
abweichende meinung ich staune etwas wie
ein land letzten wochen
leute denen früher ein luftgewehr schon
zu viel des waffenexports gewesen wäre
jetzt die waffengattungen gar nicht
schwer genug sein können die die da in
die ukraine gebracht werden hier aus
deutschland und ich hab ich habe gar
nicht grundsätzlich gegen die
waffenlieferung ich wäre sogar
seinerzeit von einem knappen jahr oder
von ja dafür gewesen als er habe gesagt
hat lasst uns doch bitte so genannte
defensivwaffen über den begriff können
wir streiten aber jedenfalls flugabwehr
sting panzerfäuste dorthin liefern da
ist er von den leuten mundtot gemacht
worden bei den grünen dem die waffen
jetzt gar nicht schwer genug sein können
und alles was ich sagen möchte ist dass
wir nicht vergessen dürfen dass das ein
dass das schwer wiegen die vorgänge sind
und wenn er bundesjustizminister sagt
damit wird man nicht zur kriegspartei
dann mag das so sein dass das im
völkerrecht so steht und man das
nachlesen kann das problem ist nur dass
entscheidet nicht der
bundesjustizminister und herr putin hat
nun damit dass er er ist ja buchstäblich
über das völkerrecht hinweg getrampelt
indem er in die ukraine einmarschiert
ist er hat das budapester memorandum von
1984 94
zerschnipselt die gasverträge auf den
eigentlich steht das muss in euro oder
rubel schönen euro oder dollar bezahlt
so dass die annahme wenn man sagt das
ist aber völkerrechtlich kein
kriegseintritt man wird nicht
kriegspartei einer in meinen augen zu
naive ist und deswegen sollte man sich
diese schritte sehr gute blinkt letzter
punkt ich bin insofern mir ist insofern
etwas wohler seit dieses treffen den
rammstein stattgefunden hat unter
führung der amerikaner wo eine wo
sozusagen ein verbund von
waffenlieferanten auch hergestellt ein
verbund der sogar über die nato
hinausgeht und das finde ich es gut
bevor sich einzelne länder hier
exponieren und dann das tut mir leid das
sagen zu müssen natürlich zur
zielscheibe offenbar die mit putin
werden können wobei wir jetzt ja auch
gelernt haben dass die ukraine diese
waffen braucht um tatsächlich in diesem
krieg standhalten zu können ja nicht
infrage gestellt ich hab nur gesagt das
hat einen preis möglicherweise den man
berücksichtigt über den reden wir auch
gleich herr krüger
bisher galt ja im ausland immer das
deutsche image so dass um der ukraine
wirklich helfen zu können müsse man die
deutschen immer zum jagen tragen was da
heute im bundestag beschlossen worden
ist was ihr auch die möglichkeiten der
bundesrepublik jetzt erweitert auch was
in ramstein gestern beschlossen worden
ist muss man das in zukunft nicht mehr
von deutschland annehmen dass
deutschland bei der unterstützung der
ukraine zum jagen getragen werden muss
also ich glaube zumindest aus der sicht
des bundeskanzlers
ist es nach wie vor so dass deutschland
im verbund mit den verbündeten handelt
und christoph schwennicke als eben
erwähnt dieses treffen in ramstein
diente dieser koordinierung
letztlich war das von der kommunikation
glaube ich sehr unglücklich im
internationalen rahmen auch ich habe die
bundesaußenminister in im baltikum
begleitet nach der pressekonferenz die
chance gegeben hat da kamen natürlich
sehr viele fragen was er eigentlich
gemeint hatte wurde dann klar gestellt
ja also wir haben gar nicht
ausgeschlossen dass wir schwere waffen
liefern das war auch wirklich nicht so
scholz hat nie den satz gesagt wir
liefern keine schweren waffen es waren
schwere waffen auf diesen industrie
listen schon darauf wenn auch nicht
diese berühmten maler schützenpanzer an
denen sich die debatte in deutschland
dann maßgeblich entzündet hat und dann
sind die amerikaner vorangegangen haben
gesagt die liefern hier in relativ hoher
stückzahl 90 fap 155 millimeter das ist
schweres geschützt aber man gar nicht
drüber reden andere alliierte sind
nachgezogen die niederlande
panzerhaubitze 2000 ein system als auch
bei der bundeswehr steht und in
deutschland ursprünglich entwickelt
worden ist und dann ist man eben diesen
schritt gegangen nach ramstein hin und
hat gesagt okay wenn die
anderen verbündeten und zwar nicht nur
in europa nicht nur in der nato jetzt
sich stärker engagieren
aufgrund einer militärischen analyse die
dahinter steht dann sind wir jetzt auch
bereit unseren beitrag indem sie nutzen
leisten dass eben diese 50 gebhard
flugabwehr panzer dann zugesagt worden
sind dass die von der deutschen
industrie geliefert werden können ramms
wenn man jetzt sich überlegt was da
möglicherweise aus deutschland geliefert
werden kann
flugabwehr panzer
schützenpanzer kampfpanzer gibt es ja
hier im land auch noch die
möglicherweise abgegeben werden kann
dann hunderte von diesen
panzerhaubitzen oder artillerie
geschossen das bringt man ja nicht
unbemerkt in die ukraine das muss
dorthin transportiert werden es gibt
jetzt auch meldungen dass russland
offenbar waffentransporte angegriffen
hat ist das möglicherweise eine gefahr
jetzt auch für die waffenlieferungen
dass russland sich ermutigt für diese
transporte anzugreifen
also wenn die russen in der lage sind
diese transporte aufzuklären
entsprechend zeitgerecht aufzuklären sie
dann beispielsweise mit luft war vor der
raketen angreift dann ist das sicherlich
eine möglichkeit für russland um diese
waffe nicht aber vom gefechtsfeld
fernzuhalten
solange diese angriffe von russischer
seite auf ukrainischem territorium
erfolgen können wir auch wie er heißt
jetzt nato-staaten die heißt
bundesprojekt deutschland wobei diese
waffenhandel ja immer auf bilateraler
basis erfolge spielte die nato keine
rolle auch dieses treffen in ramstein
ispa nato treffen gewesen und dieses
noch einmal deutlich zu machen aber wenn
die auf ukrainischem boden angegriffen
werden dann ist das glückszustand nehmen
wir zu dem wir zurzeit haben durch die
russen aber möglich und b dann wieder
eine kriegshandlung die kriegshandlungen
der ukraine ist der präsentation
zeitweilig in den bereich der
kriegsverbrechen zu orten sind das
bleibt so noch eine anmerkung zu dem was
der ständige gerade gesagt hat ich teile
seiner auffassung auch wenn unser
justizminister sagt alles was wir machen
das bisher noch rechtens dann muss ich
ihnen recht geben mir schöne das ist
dann eine frage der wahrnehmung sage ich
mal die wahrnehmung von bally mit guten
lüfter einander so
wenig wir haben ja jetzt gehört was
alles möglich sein könnte was gerade die
bilateralen
waffenlieferungen also von deutschland
in die ukraine angeht wir wissen sich
ganz genau was da in nächster zeit
ankommen wie schnell das geht es geht ja
auch um die ausbildung ukrainischer
soldaten das muss auch entsprechend
logistisch alles hinhauen
aber ist dieser effekt für die ukraine
auch wichtig auch ein psychologischer
effekt uns wird jetzt geholfen
die jetzt massiv geholfen welche
bedeutung hat diese dieser
psychologische effekt für die
ukrainische bevölkerung
ist schon wirklich da ich glaube wir
müssen auch verstehen
nicht wirklich wie die frage wie schnell
die waffenlieferungen danach erfolgen
werden weil zum beispiel vor zwei tagen
noch routine auch eine rede gehalten
indem er sagte wir müssen jetzt die den
austauschbaren da ria in ostmitteleuropa
in den usa aktive aktivieren und
ausbauen weil es gibt schon menschen die
auch an unserer seite stehen und wir
müssen dann diese menschen mit unseren
argumenten sozusagen liefern und unsere
position erklären und jahre da ist schon
eine gefahren das mit der zeit
vielleicht eher öffentlich jetzt auch
auf die regierung nicht so hoch sein
wird zum beispiel und dann frage ich
mich auch wie die waffen dann geliefert
werden und ob sie über den großen umfang
geliefert werden außerdem ist auch was
ich trage zum waschen stellen wir uns
vor putin würde bestimmte territorien im
osten der ukraine gewinnt im süden der
ukraine und würde dann sagen okay wir
sollen jetzt auf waffenstillstand
einigen ja und dann würde was auch klar
ist dem renault sein wir brauchen jetzt
keinen stillstand weil die daten steht
stand und sie bringen würde und dann
frage ich mich auch auf den westen dann
bereit wäre weiterhin waffen zu liefern
wenn die muss man dann sagt sie brauchen
waffenstillstand wir sind ein besonderer
aspekt ja eigentlich zu sagen wenn
russland tatsächlich gebiete und sagt so
wir sind jetzt saturiert die man so
schön sagt jetzt können wir ja aufhören
jetzt kann man waffenstillstand
verhandeln gerade das bezug dann dass
die uhr dass putin sein knicksten dann
doch teilweise erreicht hat das ist dass
es sich eine vorstellung wie es in der
russischen führung so gibt man hat ja
jetzt auch dann ab geschichtet gesagt
jetzt geht es nicht mehr um die ganze
ukraine es geht jetzt um
regionen don was es geht um die
landbrücke auf die krim hin
es war jetzt jüngst ein general der
gesagt hat ja es geht auch noch um
transnistrien das würde heißen odessa
und sozusagen die gesamte küstenlinie
der ukraine zum schwarzen meer und zum
als auch schon mehr
das ist ja genau der grund warum es
diese waffenlieferungen gibt
us-außenminister blinken hat das auch
gesagt die ukraine darf diesen krieg
nicht verlieren
außerdem hat gesagt die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen aber letztlich
geht es ja darum die ukraine und die
ukrainischen streitkräfte durch diese
waffenlieferungen in eine position zu
bringen dass sie stark genug ist um ein
diktat frieden durch putin zu verhandeln
scholz hat auch gesagt ein diktat
frieden durch putin ist politisch nicht
akzeptabel das ist glaube ich
mittlerweile die einheitliche meinung
der westlichen staaten und das setzt
natürlich voraus dass die ukraine
militärisch in der lage ist wo sie
sozusagen nicht kurz vor der
kapitulation diese verhandlungen führen
muss sondern aus einer position der
stärke in der sie bewiesen hat dass die
der russischen armee auch weiterhin
widerstehen kann
es ist ja schon angesprochen worden
transnistrien das ist ein abtrünniges
gebiet der republik moldau ganz nah am
nato staaten rumänien gelegen ist wenn
sollte den wir können alles wir kennen
aus den fernsehnachrichten ja die karte
sollte es der russischen armee gelingen
also die ganze südküste einzunehmen eben
nicht nur die landbrücke zu grinsen und
weiter bis transnistrien also auch
odessa einzunehmen kann man dann sagen
dass putin den krieg gewonnen hat wenn
das gelingt wenn sozusagen die ukraine
auch vom schwarzen meer abgetrennt ist
also der verlust der hafenstadt odessa
oder überhaupt dieser landbrücke eine
stimme wäre ein sehr schwerer verlust
für die ukraine und es würde nie gesagt
das positiv die geostrategische lage
dort an wenig verändert oder sogar
deutlich verändern und das würde für die
ukraine dann noch schwieriger werden von
daher aber prinzip hoffnung hoffe ich
dass es der ukraine weiterhin gelingt zu
verhindern dass die angriffe auf besser
zu laufen durch entsprechende bindung
von kräften auch immer saison und ich
hoffe dass die ukraine auch den weiteren
vormarsch dann in dieser richtung
stoppen kann auf der anderen seite muss
ich festhalten ich möchte die aussage
dass genau morgen meine karriere
nicht überbewerten das ist nicht der
russische generalstab sondern ein regal
generalmajor also unter den generell ein
relativ niedriger die scart erste
aussagen zweite aussage mit meinem
kenntnisstand ich richtig ist ein führer
in der truppe
diese aussage gemacht hat und sie ist
auch weiterhin von der russischen seite
durch andere quellen beispielsweise
lawrow oder andere nicht bestätigt
worden dennoch noch einmal zurückkommen
auf ihre frage ja wenn es den russen
gelingt die gesamte schwarzmeerküste in
die algen zu bekommen hat die ukraine
und dann auch die unterstützten länder
haben dann auch ein problem weil dieser
lage dadurch erheblich schwieriger das
kommt dann kommt übrigens noch etwas
hinzu wenn ich das ergänzen dass herr am
skate sagte es hat nicht nur
geostrategisch erhebliche oder hätte
nicht nur geostrategisch erhebliche
auswirkungen der küstenstreifen und
damit die häfen für die ukraine
wegfielen sondern natürlich auch
wirtschaftlicher also viel was die
ukraine herstellt die ukraine herstellt
dafür brauchen sie schiffe oder oder
waggons low das ist im moment sowieso
nicht ausführen na ja also das würde ich
so nicht sagen dafür natürlich finde da
im rahmen des möglichen noch was stadt
ja das ist auch gut weil die welt vom
weizen aus der ukraine zu einem großen
teil auch lebt und weil die ukraine sehr
viel geld verdient mit diesem weizen die
ist die kornkammer ist deswegen immer
schon leider auch kriegsgebiet immer
wieder geworden in der geschichte und es
ist ja offensichtlich dass dass russland
die eisenbahnlinien zerstören lässt dann
lässt sich darüber nichts mehr
abtransportieren und die häfen in
besetzen möchte dann lässt sich darüber
nicht zum abtransportieren und sie könne
neben weizen nicht mit dhl oder oder
oder oder sonstigen verschicken da
brauchen sie große schiffe dafür ich
wollte noch eines sagen weil wir bei
dieser transparenz sozusagen des
transportes waren auch der panzer jetzt
dorthin heran es hat gesagt es kann
natürlich einen beschuss auf
ukrainischem boden stattfindet könnte
auch einen beschuss auf noch nicht
ukrainischen also dann
möglicherweise nato bodensee riskiert
dass die ich sage nur das heißt nicht
dass es erst dann nach der grenze
stattfindet und was mich wirklich
erstaunt und darauf habe ich noch keine
antwort bekommen vielleicht hat sie
jemand in der runde als die sowjetunion
den afghanistan krieg geführt hat
die mudschaheddin aufmunitioniert
aufgerüstet ist unter die halskrause
welche amerikaner gewusst haben
möglicherweise geht die serie million an
diesem krieg zugrunde was auch stimmt
denn das war nicht nur
glasnost und perestroika und gorbatschow
sondern auch die schwächung durch diesen
krieg ich verstehe nicht ganz und damals
stand nicht in der washington post was
geliefert wurde schön die liste wie
jetzt wo wir also wirklich die die
marder und die gebhardts und munitions
hülsen oder die
munitionskisten einzeln zählen und
angeben ich verstehe es vielleicht ein
bisschen widersinnig wenn ich das als
journalist sage weil wir sind darauf
geeicht möglichst viel wissen zu wollen
aber ob das so besonders weise ist alles
so transparent zu machen stelle ich in
abrede damals war jedenfalls meiner
erinnerung kann ich nicht sagen weil ich
noch zu jung aber das hat sich nach
gelesen haben war es nicht der fall dass
da so detailliert darüber berichtet
wurde was die cia den user händen
gegeben hat und das war das tut ihr die
bundesregierung auch nicht also das neue
regus ministerium argumentiert seit
wochen auch auf nachfragen unsererseits
dann immer dass man eben im detail nicht
alles sagt und man sagen der panzer sind
jedenfalls immer wieder eine panzer sind
jetzt panzer die bei der industrie auf
dem hof stehen aber von dem was
geliefert worden ist hat die
bundesregierung relativ zurückhaltend
kommuniziert und das hat natürlich auch
dazu beigetragen dass
in der öffentlichkeit
und auch aus dem politischen raum zum
teil befördert genau der eindruck
entstanden ist er dann entstanden ist
nämlich dass die bundesregierung sehr
zögerlich ist bei den waffenlieferungen
das war denke ich zu treffen wenn man
guckt welche art von systemen geliefert
worden ist nicht unbedingt bei den
stückzahlen die dann dahinter stehen
wenn sie schon befürchten dass
möglicherweise russland angriffe auf den
nachschub auf nato gebiet
veranstalten könnte die tatsache dass
jetzt so massives kriegsgerät geliefert
wird um gerade diesen lückenschluss im
süden zu verhindern zum beispiel
könnte dass russland tatsächlich dann
dazu bringen diese rote linie zu ziehen
zu sagen also wenn ihr jetzt weiter so
schweres und auch
hocheffektives wie sagt man
hocheffektive gefechtsfeldwaffen liefert
dann sehen wir dass tatsächlich als
kriegseintritt an ich sag jetzt einsatz
sehen wiederum journalisten sehr ungern
sehen ich weiß es nicht herr keller ich
weiß nur dass die gefahren natürlich
steigt die schwerwiegender diese waffen
sind und ich würde mal sagen wenn
wladimir putin sagt macht euch nichts
vor schnelle schläge sind denkbar und
möglich und sie sind eigentlich in
vorbereitung ist dass möglicherweise ein
bluff aber nicht zwingend ein bluff und
der unterschied in militär strategie zum
zur digitalen welt beispielsweise
digitalen welt können wir immer sagen
trial and error ja da können wir auch
mal mit der beta-version link hier
sollte man kein prinzip des trial and
error anwenden denn diesen error diesen
fehler den machst du nur einmal der hat
taktische atomwaffen hat auch
strategisch atom und das sollte man
immer mit dem blick halten und das ist
der grund warum ich mich persönlich auch
das sage ich auch ganz offen jetzt nicht
zu denen gehört habe die mit lust und
wonne auf den bundeskanzler
eingeschlagen haben als er da ich fand
dann auch nachvollziehbar zu spät und
nicht gut kommuniziert aber gesagt hat
warum er hier so zurückhaltend ist nicht
weil er
angst hat oder oder oder oder oder
zaubert oder sich nicht entscheiden kann
sondern weil er genau diese fragen im
hinterkopf hatte vermeldet was erwarten
denn die ukraine die menschen der
ukraine aber auch die politische führung
in kiew eigentlich vom westen über das
hinaus was jetzt alles besprochen worden
ist biden hat ja auch angekündigt die
militärhilfe noch mal massiv auszuweiten
viele milliarden dollar in die hand zu
nehmen
es gab ja auch die erwartung dass der
westen eine sogenannte flugverbotszone
über der ukraine errichtet ganz zu
beginn des krieges was erwarten die
ukraine eigentlich noch mehr engagement
noch mehr stärkere direkte eingriffe
westlicher staaten und das zu verhindern
was egon ramms grade skizziert hat dass
die ukraine quasi im norton im osten und
süden eingekreist wird
ich habe in erster linie dass man
wirklich versteht warum konflikten stand
und wir kriegen das ist nur eine folge
des konfliktes
und das ist einfach militärischer
auseinandersetzen die heute erleben der
konflikt zwischen dem trainer und muss
man dauert eigentlich jahrzehnte und es
war immer in russland wichtigen regionen
staat und die britische gesellschaft zu
vernichten 2 heute zum beispiel
ukrainischen besser wurde jetzt ein
dokument diskutiert das ist
wahrscheinlich von der partei einiges
russland
entstand und stand in dieser art ein wo
es darum geht dass russland jetzt also
einen neuen staat ausrufen möchte und
das heißt sämtliche russ eigentlich
wiederum sagen wir wiederum ihre
geschichte zu tun und man möchte man
einen gewählte schaffen und den ganzen
ort pinguinen betreffen wird und dann
auf den süden gegangen und es geht
wiederum darum dass für russland ukraine
als identitätsstiftend ist das bedingt
dass ganze direktorin das auch zu sagen
auch damals auf die kinos das ist ein
alltägliches erreicht ausbildungen im
neuen jahrzehnt darauf wurde ein
wirklich die ganze identität und
russland aufgebaut und heute wurde zum
beispiel gesagt es geht nicht um das
ganze dritte runde umdrehen da stimmten
es geht um das große tor und das
betrifft eigentlich schon auch qi und
wir sollen den jetzt nicht mehr einfach
betrauen und denken dass er sich auch
dort einige zum beispiel in diesen
dokument da wird gesagt dass auf
grundlage dass wir ein russisches dass
ihr einen neuen staat ausrufen sollen
auf grundlage unserer historischen und
genetischen verwandtschaft und die
orthodoxie soll als 100 1 in diesen
staates gelten daher möchte ich wirklich
sagen dass dieser konzept das die
rektorin und prägen wenn dies für
russland ein als konzeptioneller raum so
zu sagen wie diese negative für diese
identität und das ist dass ich glaube
was ihr bis heute nicht verstanden haben
wir klare sprechen über den krieg als
präsentierten der politik aber der
konflikt ist eigentlich ich bezeichne
das was einst ein existenzieller
konflikt man am ende eigentlich bleibt
nur ein staat in der form in der heute
zum beispiel in existiert oder husten
nach diesem konflikt wird sich russland
ändern weil das betriebsamt die
identität und nach diesem rückblick
werden wir sehen ob im regen als staaten
auch alles gesellschaft
haben es also wenn da die identität der
ukraine von russland gar nicht
akzeptiert und das als reine
verfügungsmasse gesehen wird auch
militärisch betrachtet
großer und wendet die massive gewalt an
die könnte sich sogar noch ausweiten
jetzt gerade auch im donbass mit
massiven militärischen aktivitäten noch
mehr zivilisten in mitleidenschaft
ziehen wird der westen da immer tatenlos
zusehen wenn das sozusagen eine form von
völkermord annimmt dass möglicherweise
auch
völkerrechtswidrige geächtete waffen
eingesetzt werden vakuum bomben oder
vielleicht sogar giftgas ist da eine
rote linie für die nato oder gilt
generell zu sagen solange ihr nicht nato
gebiet berührt auch mit allen fußbreit
sind wir da zwar waffenlieferanten aber
trotzdem zuschauer
dieses risiko ich sage das ganz
vorsichtig kann bestehen kann aus dem
grunde bestehen weil der westen ja nicht
möchte dass er in diesen krieg und dann
riecht und dritter welt sich oder
nukleare einsatz hineingezogen werden
soll oder hineingezogen wird das ist
nicht die absicht der westlichen
regierungen sondern im prinzip mit sage
ich dass man etwas härter werden die
ukrainischen soldaten die ukrainischen
bürger zurzeit zum werkzeug gemacht auch
der westlichen interessen was sicherlich
nicht falsch ist ich sage immer den satz
wir müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
dass der die freiheit europas die
demokratie in europa vor allem in den
westlichen und mittleren teil europas
zur zeit in der ukraine durch
ukrainische soldaten und ukrainische
bürger verteidigt hat das hat mich ein
ganz wichtiger satz der letztendlich
auch die brücke dafür darstellt warum
man der ukraine hilfe leisten muss in
diesem falle
ich kann das was formell nicht gesagt
hat er aus eigener anschauung was die
geschichte angeht und den willen kopien
zahlungen ist ja dieser wille schon mal
eine zeit lang weg gewesen jedes team
hat sich ja die system was nicht bedient
jetzt 192 den west ost konflikt für
beendet erklärt jetzt hat die budapester
konvention mit unterschieden von der
ukraine und verlusten von den
parlamenten ratifiziert worden ist und
der damalige präsident bush war und
jelzin haben ja noch einen zusätzlichen
vertrag geschlossen im jahr 1997 der
ebenfalls wieder ratifiziert worden ist
von beiden parlamenten in denen jelzin
der ukraine die territoriale integrität
in die verletzlichkeit der grenzen
garantiert und dann kam ein anderer ließ
vladimir putin und er hat angefangen von
nokia oder groß mustern oder anderen
dingen zu träumen und er spricht ja auch
von den kommt bei uns nicht so gut an
klein russen die ukraine den weißrussen
also belarus und den großen sankt
petersburg und moskau und das will er
alles als ein russisches ich brauche das
ganz bewusst den begriff reich unter ein
dach bringen und aus seiner absicht von
daher muss ich frau melnik in dieser
frage recht geben wenn er diese ziele
nicht erreicht muss man sich die frage
stellen wird er nie auf oder an welcher
stelle hört er auf oder mit welchem teil
gibt es sich möglicherweise zufrieden
das kann aber bedeuten dass es eine
lange auseinandersetzung wird und das
kann bedeuten dass er an dieser stelle
nie aufhört das haus liegen ja ich sag
mal flossen konstrukte wie auch immer
drei der möglicherweise für die ukraine
auch nicht zu beenden ist trotz der
unterstützung des westens und das macht
die sache noch schwieriger
herausgestellt habe dass man nur nur
anschluss frage befürchten sie dass ist
zu befürchten dass
dieser krieg jetzt immer weitergeht wenn
sich sozusagen kaum eine eine
entscheidung ergibt aus dieser aus
diesen ausländischen krieg aus diesen
kriegsverlauf dass wir das in so eine
art wird am großen konflikt gesagt in
einem stellungskrieg so aller erster
weltkrieg da auch geraten könnten was
dann auf jahre hinaus diese unsägliche
situation an zementiert
ich da vielleicht noch mal haben an
allen anderen aspekten würden houston
handeln zunächst mal versucht auch mit
ihren strategischen zielen anlieferern
zu gehen und tier in ihre gewalt zu
bekommen und auf diese art und nicht die
regierung aus dem amt zu jagen
die regierung von faschisten
drogensüchtig nicht gebraucht die
begriffe absichtlich noch mal und das
ist ja nicht gelungen so wenn jetzt es
tatsächlich so sein sollte dass
beispielsweise der der krieg im süden
mit der ob last saison beendet ist weil
die wussten nicht weiterkommen dass
möglicherweise diese flügelzange die
ständige vorhin angesprochen hat mit
blick auf den don was nicht funktioniert
dann ist die frage zu stellen was machen
die russen dann
voraussetzung dafür ist aber weiterhin
der mit hoher moral betriebene
hartnäckige widerstand der ukrainischen
soldaten und der ukrainischen bürger ich
sage das immer wieder
dann muss man sehen wie die russen sich
dann weiter verhalten werden das heißt
wenn sie den donner bass nicht gänzlich
in die hand bekommen wenn sie unten im
süden nicht weiterkommen und das können
wir können die ukraine mit unserer
unterstützung für schaffen dann kann es
vielleicht ein umdenken bei den russen
einsetzen aber die antwort ist auch ein
bisschen hoffnung und hoffnung aufgeben
würde gerne noch einen aspekt da
aufnehmen von harel skaat gesagt hat
herr krüger nämlich dass das motiv
derjenigen die die ukraine unterstützen
wollen auch mit schweren waffen ja oft
ist dass die ukraine für uns freieren
demokratie mit verteidigen in europa
ist man ein bisschen wohlfeil wenn man
das so sagt denn wir sind ja in der sich
bequemen position zu sagen schaut was
die alles für uns machen ohne dass wir
uns selbst die hände schmutzig machen
müssen naja ich glaube das stimmt an dem
punkt
da geht es dann auch um die weiteren
szenarien wo man einfach sehen was putin
hat ja auch noch andere forderungen
erhoben er und es geht putin natürlich
um das große russland aber es geht putin
natürlich auch um die geopolitische
stellung russlands in der welt und die
die ordnung in europa ja das ist ja auch
eine eine ansage dass er diese ordnung
auch mit mit waffengewalt eben zerstören
will und das betrifft dann vielleicht in
erster linie noch nicht uns wenn wir
hier in berlin sitzen aber sehr direkt
zum beispiel die menschen im baltikum
die menschen in polen die teilweise eben
eine gemeinsame grenze mit russland
haben
und auch staaten die sozusagen als
profession von russland einkalkuliert
sind wie die republik moldau die auch
gar nicht die möglichkeit hätten sich
militärisch zu verteidigen die haben
keine streitkräfte wie die ukraine die
jetzt längere zeit irgendwie einen
russischen angriff standhalten könnten
das geht letztlich bis auf dem balkan wo
russland versucht zum beispiel die
rezessionstendenzen der republica srpska
zu unterstützen wo letztlich die gesamte
ordnung die sich in europa etabliert hat
und zwar mit belegungen und dem zutun
russlands nach dem ende des kalten
krieges zerstört werden soll und von
daher denke ich trifft das schon zu und
dann muss ich noch mal sowohl bei frauen
als auch bei den rams anschließen auch
wenn wenn putin
jetzt sage ich mal in anführungszeichen
nur den süden und den osten der ukraine
gewinnen würde
gibt es ja keinerlei
garantie dafür dass er sich damit
zufriedengeben würde er wenn das
gelingen würde militärisch die
ukrainischen kräfte die entlang der
kontakt linie 450 kilometer front
stationiert sind aufzuräumen das sind
ungefähr die hälfte der der ukrainischen
bodentruppen dann hätte er natürlich
ganz andere möglichkeiten aus dieser
richtung kommen erneut auf kiel vor zu
marschieren und die gebiete einzunehmen
hier sozusagen für sein großes land
beanspruchen möchte und vielleicht wenn
ich ergänzen der verkehr ja ich glaube
dass wohlfeil da auch nicht der
angemessene legitime vorwurf an uns
selbst wäre denn keiner lehnt sich doch
hier in dem lehnstuhl zurück und sagt na
die werden das schon für uns richten
richtig ist doch aber erstens wurde mal
erzählt die für die sicherheit
deutschlands würde am hindukusch
verteidigt ich würde mal sagen also die
nukleare also hier auf jeden fall hier
auch am hindukusch man muss immer
präzise sind haben sie recht vielen dank
also auch am hindukusch hat herr struck
gesagt also hier ist das
offensichtlicher dass die dass
demokratie in der ukraine und in kiel
verteidigte gehören alle den mai damit
erlebt wir haben diese demokratischen
aufbruch erlebt das ist ja auch richtig
dass leute sagen putin ja möchte dieses
reich herstellen von dem er träumt aber
bekämpften natürlich auch unsere systeme
bekämpft die demokratie die ihm
buchstäblich auf die pelle rückt in
diesen in diesen ländern und was wäre
die alternative also zusammen wenn man
sagt es ist so wohlfeil sich hier also
eingreifen kann es nicht sein boots on
the ground sind nicht vorstellbar schon
eine flugverbotszone ist außerhalb
dessen was ich mir vorstellen möchte so
dass ich sagen würde das ist die
situation aber keiner legt ja hier die
hände in den schoß und sagt na ja die
ukraine werde es schon richten der
us-verteidigungsminister lloyd austin
hat ja jetzt gesagt man müsse russland
so schwächen in diesem krieg da ging es
ja um die frage nicht nur die ukraine zu
unterstützen sondern eine
nachkriegsordnung damit nicht sich das
wiederholt was jetzt gerade passiert man
müsse dafür russland so schwächen damit
sie nicht mehr in der nahe
ge ist oder mit russland nicht mehr der
lage ist ein nachbarland welches auch
immer mit einer derartigen terrorakt zu
überziehen kann man das kann man
russland so schwächen ohne tatsächlich
irgendwann mal klicks partei zu werden
also erstens haben sich schon andere
enttäuscht darin wie wie schnell
russland die puste ausgehen würde ich
glaube die die leidensfähigkeit und auch
die durchhaltefähigkeit russland sollte
man nicht unterschätzen damit
glorifizieren ich nichts mache ich
nichts glorifizieren sondern nur
hinweise geben diese auch in der
geschichte gibt dass das auch napoleon
schon gedacht hat er sei durch und er
war eben nicht durch in dem fall hat er
angegriffen aber also ob man wirklich
natürlich steckt dahinter das gleiche
was ich was ich erzählt habe aus den
zeiten von brosinski dem
sicherheitsberater der damalige
amerikanische regierung last und sie in
afghanistan letztlich
ausbluten ist jetzt vielleicht ein sehr
mutiges wort aber ich weiß nicht ob das
aufgehen kann ob man wirklich sich lange
auf so einen krieg einrichten kann damit
allmählich russland vermehrt wird und
nun seine kraft gebracht wird anderswo
auch noch einzugreifen ich weiß nicht ob
das eine eine sehr kluge strategie ist
weil das durchhaltevermögen
halte ich für bei putin jedenfalls für
sehr sehr hoch und den willen für sehr
sehr stark
ist wie ist sie das aus mit
durchhaltewillen russlands und der
möglichkeit umgekehrt dass der westen
wie aus den angekündigt hat russland so
schlecht dass es keine gefahr für die
nachbarn mehr ist
also ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz
anknüpfend an die bemerkung von der in
grüner vollen stichwort strategische
ziele punktlos und wir haben sie nicht
alle erfasst ist die aussage ist richtig
dass von dem was putin zurzeit macht ist
ja er will sich einen cordon sanitaire
oder einen cordon sie täten um sein
eigenes land bauen damit er die
bedrohung der nato nicht mehr fürchten
muss ich vermute das mal so das hat ja
nur noch die schweden und die finden
dazu bewogen darüber nachzudenken
kurzzeitig nato mitglied zu werden oder
einer kurzen zeitachse das heißt die
reaktionen die im westen passieren sind
völlig andere als lade mir punkten sich
vorgestellt hat mit seiner strategie mit
der dann die ukraine angegriffen von da
her da sind viele dinge noch für mich
sage ich mal überhaupt blick offen die
möglicherweise jetzt wird es wieder
schwierig weil putin für mich im
augenblick kein rational denkender
mensch mehr ist für einen rational
denkenden menschen zumindest ich sag mal
einen nachdenkprozess auslösen würden
weil die man dann möglicherweise zu
anderen ergebnis kommt zu ihrer frage
herr keller die
russischen streitkräfte haben bei ihrem
angriff auf kiew und rundum kiew eine
menge material verloren und dieses
material ersetzen kann putin mit seinen
streitkräften auch nicht von heute auf
morgen und wir müssen bedenken dass bei
der streitkräftereform der russen seit
2008 letztendlich die jedes truppenteile
an letzter stelle gestanden haben alles
andere war vorher dran die heeres
truppenteilen letzter stelle und vor
allen dingen dabei sind hauptsächlich
berücksicht worden die heeres
truppenteil aus dem militär bezeugt
lässt also das was unmittelbar an die
nato grenze stößt bis einschließlich
ukraine das heißt er kann möglicherweise
noch verstärkungskräfte aus dem osten
aus sibirien nach führen aber diese
verstärkungskräfte werden eine andere
qualität haben sowohl das die ausrüstung
angeht also was die moral angeht der
moralische faktor ist ohnehin schon ein
problem gewesen auch beim kampf um das
letzte mal war das bewusst so da haben
die da haben die ukrainer ihre
moralische überlegenheit bewiesen und
ich bin fest davon überzeugt einen blick
auf den dom wasser unten im süden von
seiten der ukraine die ersten erfolge
erzielt werden dann kann möglicherweise
der gestern für die russen dort auch
relativ schnell kippen und dann wären
wir da einer stelle wo die russen dann
feststellen dass die kriegst du nicht
erreichen und dann muss man sich die
frage stellen was machen sie dann und
die frage es tut mir leid kann ich
zurzeit im moment auch nicht beantworten
von wladimir putin hört man ja immer er
fühle sich von der nato bedroht
zumindest nicht was für eine
sicherheitsbedürfnisse angeht richtig
ernst genommen aber ist es nicht so dass
er gar nicht militärisch bedroht wird
und eigentlich auch von der nato gar
nicht militärisch bedroht werden soll
oder dass die nato das gar nicht vor hat
warum sollte sie das auch tun
fürchtet er vielmehr eben das was wir
als demokratie rechtsstaat
empfinden und eine pluralistische offene
tolerante gesellschaft dass das
sozusagen wie eine art ja fast wie eine
pandemie dann über russland hereinbricht
ist das der eigentliche grund für sein
verhalten jetzt die ukraine in schutt
und asche zu legen
sich bedroht weil ich ja das ist sehr
interessant wie er in der sprache umgeht
und wir waren uns eigentlich in der
russischen ideologie gar nicht
auseinandergesetzt wir haben werden sehr
oft das als propaganda abgetan
und ich glaube was wir nicht immer
durchschauen können dass er wenn er von
russland spricht und sagt rossmann wird
von nato bedroht dann nehmen wir so war
das ist dass direktoren von wussten dass
wir uns durch unsere raketen und so
weiter aber eigentlich unter russland
meint er historische territorien und
dahinter wird eine dem ringer verstanden
und auch viele hausverstand er spricht
einfach von diesem konzeptionellen lahm
und wenn dann die nato sozusagen jetzt
eine strategische ziele
unter dieser strecke gesehen wird
eigentlicher aufbauen dieses konzept
systems
im wege stehen dann ist es schon eine
bedrohung für aber ich möchte ihnen
dient zusammenhang und dann wird alles
tun er wird alles tun um diese
territorien zu bekommen ich möchte aber
so einen anderen aspekt reinbringen
wartung krieg kann es jetzt kommen oder
nicht ich glaube nicht dass der westen
mit einheits umschlag antworten wird
wenn es zu einem umschlag bekommen würde
aber ich schließe das nicht aus dass
alles dafür machen wird und diese
territorien zu bekommen und dass er so
einen atomschlag nicht verschließen
würde was interessant ist und ich bin
gespannt was die kollegen auch sagen
würden aber ich glaube vor dem
atomschlag bei diesem imaginären sei
nicht so atomschlag haben wir an unsere
handlungsfähigkeit ihr könnt alles tun
wir können uns erscheinen wie wir die
ukraine unterstützen dieses museen
stärken können wenn es zu einem
atomschlag kommen würde juli wir unsere
handlungsfähigkeit trainieren und ich
glaube das dürfen wir uns nicht zulassen
glück hat das war ja auch ein wichtiges
argument dass olaf scholz mehrfach jetzt
vorgebracht hat wir müssen wir dürfen da
nicht einfach blind jetzt agieren wir
müssen uns genau überlegen was wir tun
weil auch eine atomare
auseinandersetzung ist denkbar
die frage ist ja aber das so klug dieses
argument zu bringen wenn man sich
überlegt dass man es ja im moment eher
für unwahrscheinlich hält dass putin
tatsächlich zu diesem mittel greifen
wird
also ich glaube es ist etwas was man im
hinterkopf haben muss und das ist glaube
ich auch dass der kanzler gemeint hat
und das meinen die amerikaner übrigens
ganz genau so ist ja nicht so dass die
amerikaner alles liefern was die ukraine
vielleicht gerne hätte thema zum
beispiel kampfjets die polnischen mit 29
dass die nicht weitergegeben worden sind
ist letztlich am widerstand der
amerikaner gescheitert da haben auch
militärische überlegungen rolle gespielt
aber vor allem dass man halt gesagt hat
das ist eine eskalation die wir nicht
wollen das war auch einer frühen phase
des krieges oder einer früher rennen
also vor butscher auf jeden fall vor der
massiven operationen die russland jetzt
im osten und dem süden der ukraine
begonnen hat da kommt man vielleicht im
verlauf der auseinandersetzung auch zu
anderen schlussfolgerungen also es
werden jetzt zum beispiel ersatzteile
geliefert die es den ukrainern
ermöglicht haben 20 ihrer kampfjets
wieder in die luft zu bringen
ich glaube und heran es möge mich
korrigieren es gibt militärisch kein
szenario für einsatz von atomwaffen ob
die jetzt taktischer und strategischer
natur sind die
putin einen militärischen sieg in der
ukraine bescheren würden ja also mir ist
kein szenario vorstellbar wo jetzt zum
beispiel der einsatz von von
gefechtsfeldwaffen im donbass
militärischen durchbruch bringen würde
der sozusagen den gesamten verlauf des
krieges auf den kopf stellen würde
was denkbar ist aber auch mit einer sehr
hohen schwelle glaube ich ist eine
nukleare machtdemonstration dass zum
beispiel ein
ein
nuklearen gefechtskopf gezündet wird
irgendwo über mehr so wie man das bis in
die 60er jahre hinein bei den
atmosphärischen oder den untersee tests
damals gemacht hat ohne dass man jetzt
ein bevölkerungszuwachs ziel angreift um
sozusagen zu signalisieren okay wir sind
bereit diese eskalationsstufe zu gehen
das hätte aber massive rückwirkungen auf
die stellung russlands in der
internationalen gemeinschaft also viele
staaten die jetzt noch mit
zusammengebissenen zähnen zu schauen
oder sogar russland unterstützen china
vor allem
würden dann gezwungen sein diese haltung
zu überdenken und
das wäre ein tabubruch nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg wie wir ihn nicht gesehen
haben der würde glaube ich russland und
putin endgültig zur internationalen
pariser machen und ich glaube diese
kalkulation die macht man im kreml auch
noch und dann wäre die zweite frage wenn
putin sich zu diesem schritt bereit
finden würde ob das russische militär an
dem punkt noch mit zieht wo das wäre
eher kontraproduktiv leider nur noch
eine minute christoph schwennicke
übernächsten montag ist er neunter meier
wollte ja putin auf einer militärparade
aus anlass des ende des zweiten
weltkriegs den großen sieg präsentieren
daraus wird wohl nichts ist das für
russland
eine oder für punkt in eine
psychologische täglich ich habe gelesen
auch die moderatorin für die festspiele
hätte ich fast gesagt ist schon
ausgesucht ich meine wir haben die
bilder von mario pohl gesehen mit dem
soldaten den russischen soldaten die den
dem sieg die einnahme mario puls
gefeiert und verkündet haben da war aber
noch gar nicht ganz mario pohl
eingenommen und es ist bis heute nicht
so fern wird er irgendeinen potemkin
jazz dorf aufbauen lassen was dann wie
ein teilsieg aussieht und dass dann
feiern und bejubelt so wird das ablaufen
was das sein wird der keller kann ich
ihnen jetzt im moment leider nicht gut
das war jedenfalls ein wichtiger termin
auf den er ja wohl hingearbeitet hat wir
haben sie natürlich auch im blick ich
bedanke mich bei notwendig bei egon
ramms bei paul anton krüger und bei
christoph schwennicke hier liebe
zuschauer noch einen hinweis liebe
zuschauerinnen und liebe zuschauer noch
ein hinweis für am kommenden samstag
finden parteitage statt von csu und von
bündnisgrünen auch überschattet und
beherrscht vom ukraine thema vom ukraine
krieg phoenix dann ab samstag am samstag
ab 10 uhr live dabei jetzt folgt phoenix
der tag mit thomas bade thema unter
anderem die pressekonferenz von joe
biden da ging es um eine massive
ausweitung der militärhilfe für die
ukraine bleiben sie bei uns